well that's that's insanity that's
insanity that's insane just so everybody
understands that again understanding the
demo of this and a lot of the undertones
that we're talking about that is great
is everything I mean I went on live
stream for eight hours twenty two months
ago and could barely break like number
sixty and seventy four askgaryvee and
i've done i've just done so it's been a
campaign you know it's just so different
i also genuinely believe me more so than
any book since crush it if you give this
to your kid your aunt your college
roommate your coworker this book i can
see right yeah cool right seriously sure
so I just really I just think it started
like that that's got it like that rush
it's nine years of every day they get
five emails I read Kashyap yesterday
[Music]
I started documenting my [ __ ] and then
once I started documenting it that [ __ ]
blew up like I get people DNA me now
they're like oh dude what you drop the
so fire I'm like really I just filmed
some dude that wanted somebody just you
know what I mean
but then so many people can relate to
the real [ __ ] hundred percent yeah the
only the only the only vulnerability one
has to documenting like this early in
the process
yeah it's faking the funk yeah like it's
all you have to do is speak the truth
yeah and you win yeah exactly like like
too many kids especially young like you
guys you know like there's a sense of
like wanting to be the expert yeah that
I think Hart's kids like but if you just
speak like yo I'm just trying to figure
this out - yeah or I have figured out
this part you know that the old you know
this document thing thing is a hundred
percent right the only thing that's
wrong that I see kids doing is trying to
act tough yeah
aka like yeah talking about [ __ ] they've
never experienced exactly so from like
18 to 19 and a half I tried every I work
their team dogs at times man
Wow and then my mom was like my mom's
account was like you know that's funny
I think all of what is going on with me
is not letting anybody's POV on me have
any impact what exactly other people's
opinions is the worst [ __ ] thing on
earth the fact that you let somebody
with an anonymous account leave a
comment on your Instagram and it hurts
your feelings for today it's [ __ ]
ridiculous be in a cocoon speak to
yourself only about yourself and run the
[ __ ] marathon cuz life's not a sprint
that's gangster son when our family
Orlando what up people making real moves
make yours now one life don't [ __ ]
waste it
- your thing man long game that's only
thing that you can get caught up in it's
so cliche don't the one thing that is
baby pop that makes me different yeah I
don't don't embellish don't let just
stay like people gonna react here
present oh you got it yeah only before
anything that gets caught up it's when
the momentum gets going yeah because
become something couldn't come to
characters for yourself just a
discipline understand yeah you caught
that little spot you caught that little
scene through the window huh
good job right cuz it's real
[Music]
congratulations Thank You Billy
right
[Music]
thank you it's so much bigger than
people realize like if you don't have a
sense of the streets you're not going to
be relevant period over the next twenty
thirty years because that's what the
Internet has it's scale of the micro
becomes the macro real simple let me
give you a couple analogies this was the
work this last year was the worst year
for the biggest artists in the world
because the Machine can't help Katy
Perry as much anymore because people are
dying the death of a thousand cuts
because tiara wax gonna get her solicits
because Kelly's gonna get listens
because little Sam's gonna get listens
cuz gonna is gonna get listens it's just
scale of alternatives this isn't about
an alternative college station running
some wax
this is SoundCloud and Spotify are big
like scale like [ __ ] MTV eighty four
scale and that changes everything
this is this is guys everything this
guy's my number one me too he's the only
person I didn't mean that led that I
can't like I can't make him I might go I
might go to his [ __ ] like tombstone
[Music]
just welcome hi 97 Ebro the crew in the
old obsession you know really really
really well I will link up to the
internet version of this in the blog
just being incredible guys so much
[Music]
[Music]
that's awesome
the C is backwards thanks guys
that's very nice stopping you couldn't
you couldn't you couldn't flip you
couldn't flip he's gonna flip that's so
awesome thanks guys I can't lose when
you're the truth nothing it's just hard
to ludus oh oh you want the shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so dead so dead even though even though
so you know about um about two years ago
my brother left this company and we
started a sports representation business
so I've gotten real educated about your
guy I've always been I'm real friendly
Brandon and like always been friends
with players because I'm such a die-hard
Jets fan and but I got real educated the
last year and like there's so much
opportunity and guys are either not
motivated they're either too romantic
and think they're gonna go to the Hall
of Fame and that's where all the money's
gonna come from and more importantly the
agents and managers are just not after
your panini sports car dealer sneaker
deal they're not doing anything and so
but the opportunity while you while
you're an NFL player there's so much to
leverage so I'm yeah I've got a much
I've always had a perspective
but I got a real perspective now so I'm
thrilled to answer I mean I think I what
i think is look a million people asked
to meet with me and like if weenie asked
me i would meet with anybody but an
active athlete has leverage not a say
straight up like every single person
that wants to meet like everybody that's
a fan of the team you're on at the
moment is an opportunity i'll meet with
a stop me with the puck I will meet with
Lachlan Edwards right now the punter the
Jets in two seconds an a-list business
person I may never meet because I'm busy
that's leverage it's very powerful I
think the biggest thing I can tell you
is you can meet a lot more people than
you think
and that's what I would figure out like
I'd be living on Twitter searching my
team's name and being like oh that guy's
a CEO of this oh he and he's going crazy
about my team let me just like this post
like one of you know when any jet player
interacts with anything I do I get
extract a squad guys diehard fandom is a
wheel arbitrage it's the number one
thing athletes should be doing right now
is searching their team forget about you
know because most I mean listen you're
super athlete like it everybody knows
who you are and it's different but like
there's a lot of ty hearts who really
know who their left tackle is who really
know who their Gunners are you know I
mean I sit with two guys at the jet
games that sit in front of me
these guys made real economics being at
Goldman Sachs
like if a Jets corner hit him up and was
like yo so that's number one that's the
number one piece of advice because
people are gonna be the Wendy's advice
was right I'm gonna have a much bigger
impact on your business empire or people
like me it's always people so but it's
the leverage while you got that shield
and that yes and when you're lucky
enough to be in the right markets
there's people for everybody who's
watching it's very simple I think that
the internet is grossly underrated
and that it blows my mind that if you
make 74 thousand dollars a year doing
something you don't love that you can
make sixty seven thousand dollars a year
or eighty-three thousand dollars a year
literally being the foremost expert
about beekeeping or running at 6:00 a.m.
or gardening peppers or selling real
estate or the town of Montclair like
like I am blown away by the long tail
financial opportunities and then doing
something you like look the great you
know we one life because forget about
the family stuff which is the real part
yeah the second part is you just work a
lot of your life like Americans work a
lot like you don't even want but friends
you do not want to actually put down on
paper what percentage of your life is
actually at work a lot and you have to
love it
from my perspective in the internet age
and this is about why the mentality of
all the things that they're fearful of
which is their parents judgment college
debt you know your spouse's point of
view why you aren't doing this ah you're
lazy or you like watching entire seasons
of the crown but complaining about your
job all the mental stuff why are we
number three what did you do to get this
number three I built a brand podcast
nation what is up it's me Gary a very
exciting day for me we're recording this
right now as the book is being launched
its launch day it's going extremely well
and I want to first start and say thank
you to all of you that are supporting I
really really really do appreciate it
but more importantly we're doing our
second pod sessions what is something
that you want people to hear
yeah honestly I'm less worried about
people like getting the book like go to
the library steal it I'm like a
BitTorrent I really just want you to
read it like I really I mean it like
listen I want you to buy a thousand
copies to like I'm all over the place on
that that part doesn't excite me what
excites me is I wrote this book as much
for you who I think is very advanced as
I did for somebody who's never done
anything on the Internet meaning for
somebody who's never done it's like time
to try like just make a one minute to
the camera on your Instagram post about
your thoughts on X period eSports WWE
like I don't care jelly shoes from the
80s like it's time number two and this
is really for you like you don't even
know how I feel about you doing this
podcast I have no idea how much or how
little impact I have on your doing this
podcast yeah I thought so because I'm
pushing all of you so hard to do voice
more than anybody and I know you're
gonna win you're about to build a much
bigger audience because a lot of people
want to watch your videos but they're
busy and now the winner on their
treadmill or going to work they're gonna
listen to this and they would have never
watched this that's a big deal so for me
I wrote this book because I can't
believe after where I was even when you
and I met where I was on the pedestal of
leadership I miss John rrah
where I've gone in the last 15 months is
a totally different plane I'm in totally
different plane fifteen months ago I
would be noticed on the streets once
every two or three days for selfie if
I'm outside for a minute I mean I'm I'm
taking 34 selfies a day I'm starting to
get weird and kind of weirdly like and I
love it I love the interaction I'm
starting to get
thank you but you know what's even more
interesting and I think this is why I
think you're special I think you're
gonna win because you have something
very real to say and you're coming from
a good place like to me I appreciate
that and metrics have some alluding to
what's going on but I'm much more I look
at metrics as with right like how many
but depth what you what makes me still
spend time with you is I think you have
depth
I have depth like I don't think I'll
again it was kind of like the Bezos and
Zuckerberg thing I don't think I'll ever
have the most points the most followers
like the most money but depth I think I
have a shot can somebody play some she's
on my livestream and she's going to be
[ __ ] Lauryn Hill 3.0 you better
[ __ ] download it that's here or wack
Seth don't [ __ ]
I want ulti or a wack music 24/7 she's
my favorite person on earth did you see
her I mean listen Emily talented
I want you listening right now it's
really good right I can't wait I can't
wait for 36 months right now it feels
like Instagram and Twitter that's what
I'm doing now with artists I'm about to
do with soccer - I've decided min a
penetrate European soccer culture mm-hmm
I might go to World Cup I think I'm
going to World Cup I'm gonna Russia Alex
look at my calendar let's take at the
beginning like what happened from the
beginning what were you before that
when vine was popping I remember a few
followers on Instagram
he was just dancing he have no it was
like one of the videos so we do skits
together they didn't go a little further
but then we just gave up on doing skits
and we just thought I shouldn't truth
all these [ __ ] wins so it's a real
brain twist like what well here's where
we got lucky and where we got [ __ ] up
the [ __ ] we put on a pestle isn't cool
it's not as good as we think and we're
in the tail end you two are gonna walk
into this office it's gonna be Sammy and
Ricky in three years and this is gonna
be out of their mouths done you're like
the by the way you guys are the last
frontier of even considering that model
it's just over make your own [ __ ]
Netflix documentary go [ __ ] an email
Hulu right now and be like you know
we're gonna make a [ __ ] Chappelle
show for you pay us remember like okay
it's weird man it's really really weird
people need content you guys have talent
if you're so talented you got an
audience like you don't need anybody in
the middle like you you're in a much
better spot then literally than
Chappelle you ever said why you haven't
done anything where anybody has any
control over anything you do but you
have audience you understand why people
signed before didn't have audience you
taken you guys are too young you're
taking [ __ ] for granted you guys have
more people watching one of your skits
than most cable TV shows have viewers
the money hasn't flown properly yet but
it will how'd it all go down you give me
the origin story like a tumblr blog or a
more presser and what was called right
from the get and what was the first
premise of it meaning like what was the
blog about
music that's out living about an hour
and a half outside the city okay you
know did that your high school built the
brand around my friends in school yeah
went out to see every weekend you know
passing on stickers throwing small bowl
events with what I could move to the
city after I graduated college DePaul
just expanded everything going school
was always about that what was the first
you work and you work you are you
putting on in terms of I here's what I
would say too many people rush to switch
I like your general energy of not
switching to early yeah just keep it 21
the longer you can just keep doing it
about them you win
but yeah man like that like your ability
with the kind of things I'm hearing and
I got to do a little more homework I
mean I know about it but like excuse me
your ability to build the coachella of
like this genre that's real that's real
[ __ ] business you can do anything
it's all about attention
it just comes down to you I said in the
last meeting some people want to make
five million and go to Jamaica and smoke
weed for rest their life and some people
want to build empires like I don't know
and then everything in between right
last few questions yes I said vice
you've ever given I'm sorry
worst advice you've ever given the worst
advice I you look back on anything you
know what I don't know enough then or
whatever I probably in my 20s and 30s
20s in my 20s I assume and I don't
remember
oh you wanna hear something insane for
most of my life probably the first 15
years of my life I didn't give any
advice which is weird cuz I'm like
spitting advice all the time now I just
did it because I didn't think I have the
audacity to I think that um if I did
give advice it would have been more
counseling than advice and I probably if
I gave bad advice it was me not
understanding that I was unique and I
was trying to give my advice that worked
for me I think what I've gotten really
good at is learning the person and
giving them advice based on them and
making it contextual and that's why I'm
very careful to speak I speak in
absolutes but I always try to be
contradiction to myself back to Mohan's
questions of like but that's me yes
self-awareness bro yeah [ __ ] seven so
you want to let the other superpower
yeah so Sal Samaras said self-awareness
my friends
[Music]